[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv
recorded on thursday february the 18th
on this week's show
will we still be in lockdown come summer
the chances are the rules will be eased
by how much and would vaccine passports
mean greater freedom
the spectators political team will tell
us about next week's
exit strategy announcement from the
prime minister we'll be joined by trevor
phillips and rod little
to discuss vaccine passports we'll take
a look at the global vaccine game
china and russia are now using to export
their vaccines a soft power to gain
favor
in developing countries how can the west
response
and finally how tv and film have given
us a renewed
interest in england's anglo-saxon
origins
all that to come in the next hour as
always if you
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel and why wouldn't you it's free
you'll never miss a program just click
the subscribe button
at the bottom right of the screen now a
very special thanks to charles stanley
for their continued support of the week
in 60 minutes charles stanley is one of
the uk's leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange
and we're delighted to have them as our
partners at spectator tv
now on monday boris johnson will set out
how
he sees england leaving its third
lockdown so what can we expect to hear
i'm joined by james forsyth the
spectator's political editor and katie
balls
our deputy political editor james
first of all before we look at what he
might say what are the forces
crowding in on them is it on the one
hand
scientific advice don't be too hasty
and tory back benches and the other
saying ridges of this lockdown
i mean that is broadly right andrew i
mean that the scientists are
essentially arguing for the first time
in this crisis
you're ahead of the curve on the virus
so let's go very slowly let's try and
drive kobe right down
the lower the number of cases the more
likely you are the less likely you are
to get a kind of mutation that could
evade the vaccines and send you back to
square one on the other hand you have
tory mps arguing
businesses are running out of money if
they can't reopen
um the economic damage is going to be
worse and what was the point of the
vaccine program if it wasn't to return
to normal
and they're making the case that you
know the political benefit comes
from being from being able to open up
before other countries
because of the success of the vaccine
program
casey how much pressure is that from the
tory back benches i think you and i have
talked before
about whereas before
this wave that hit us again before
christmas there had been quite a lot in
the
late summer early autumn a lot of tory
pressure
on the prime minister to ease up the
then locked down and he did some of that
it doesn't i think is it true to say
that this latest
uh wave of the pandemic has been
so virulent that that kind of locked
down pressure isn't as strong or
removal of lockdown pressure is not as
strong as it was
i think that is fair to say it is uh not
as strong as it has been previously but
it is starting to bubble to the surface
again
and i think that right now everyone is
waiting for this road map so
the only group really willing to go
public is the covert recovery group
steve baker uh mark harper
in a way the usual suspects and we've
heard from them this week talking about
concerns
the government is shifting strategy by
focusing on case numbers
rather than just whether or not the nhs
is overwhelmed in terms of how to ease
the lockdown
however i get the impression that this
group are not going to be lonely for too
long and if you do have a situation
where boris johnson in this road map
suggests
and we don't know for sure how far they
go on dates but suggests that you know
hospitality won't be open until july
august in in a way that would resemble
something close to normal
i think you'll start to get a wider tory
backlash
and ultimately if you look at that third
lockdown where there was a smaller
rebellion than previous ones it was down
to a few factors that
you pointed to so the fact you had the
new variant
spreading is so fast this worry about
the
high death toll it would lead to i think
that now you have vaccines a lot of
those factors in the views of the
bulks the mainstream tory mps um
are going to go away they're going to
fall away and i think
when it comes to talking about if all
the over 50s have been vaccinated
they have some protection i think at
that point um
many tory mps not just the covered
recovery group think this is a different
illness
um so if boris johnson is listening more
to scientific advisors who
are not quite calling for zero covert
but according for this uh you know
tightly controlled cases
even once the vulnerable vaccinated i
think that is going to get quite
strong opposition in the tory party even
if we've just had a you know difficult
situation in hospitals
james before we come on to what the
prime minister might say
just frame some of the considerations
obviously vaccine policy
is is is clearing the way for some kind
of relaxation we
don't know uh how much but i see again a
new emphasis too
on testing lots of rapid reaction
reaction testing that 65
of the population may be regularly
tested now with these rapid
tests so the testing is now becoming a
another
sort of arm in the government's response
along with the vaccine
yeah and i think the government's theory
is that
testing essentially allows you to reopen
before everyone has been vaccinated
so you encourage people to test
regularly if they're going back into
work
their workplace or back into school and
that should basically
hopefully keep the most infectious
people at home
rather than out spreading the virus and
that that should ease the pressure
on the nhs until the vaccination program
has finished i think we are
heading to a broader philosophical
debate though
about how we handle uh viruses in
general in this country
uh i think that lots of tory mps at the
end of this once everyone has been
vaccinated they just want
to go back to normal uh i think there
are people on the public health side who
think that you know
the the british habit of going to work
when when they're
sick is unhealthy and that needs to be
stopped
um and i think that you know i think
there'll be an interesting balancing act
there i also think we are going to end
up uh
almost inevitably with a kind of
pandemic alert
level a bit akin to a terrorism alert
level that you know we'll
all wake up one morning and because of
some worry about
uh some new virus somewhere you know
it'll be
back to wearing masks on public
transport that kind of thing um
so i think i think we are i don't think
we are going to go back to
the status quo ante i think we are going
to become a society that is more
nervous about viruses um uh
going forward from this in much the same
way that you saw
a shift in in behavior in places like
taiwan after sars
i think you're going to see a similar
change here
so james what do we think the headlines
will be
uh next week we know the papers have
been full of speculation i've seen
downing street warning other journalists
off some of what's been
printed and for this government thursday
here we are in the middle of thursday
monday's a long time away we know a lot
can happen with this government
in its reaction but what do we think the
headlines will be
well i think one of the big questions is
the government
had under pressure from its mps promised
this roadmap on the 22nd of february
uh but the data from the vaccination
program
is only just coming in now and so i
think that is one of the big things i
think
what you will see from the government is
and it
it will try and do three things it wants
to carry on
under promising and over delivering so
it doesn't want to set dates that it
can't
meet but it also needs to give
tory mps and businesses enough hope that
um that people keep going i think there
is i think there is definitely a worry
among
some cabinet ministers at the moment but
the government's tone is so downbeat
but there is a real risk that businesses
just throw in the towel they say well
look i'm never going to get to
reopen at full capacity for so long um
i might as well shut up shop now rather
than wait until i kind of run out of
money and and because even with the
support the businesses are running out
of cash at the moment
so i mean that that's that is the
question i mean i think the big thing is
as well but the government wants to go
to wait two weeks after each relaxation
to see what happens so i suspect on
march the 8th schools will go back
you know things like tennis and uh golf
will be allowed
outside uh people will maybe be allowed
to
you know be grateful for small mercies
be allowed to sit down outside with
somebody else and have a cup of coffee
and then i think you know then they want
to wait two weeks to see what effect
that all has on the r number
before you move to the next phase uh i
think the question is essentially
how quickly do you get to go
back inside a pub or a restaurant and i
i suspect at the moment
uh the beginning you know the mayday
bank holiday is when i would be
beginning to think about that
as as lightly
kitty where does this leave the labour
party now i see
kyostama's doing a kind of big relay has
been doing a big relaunch speech
we know the pandemic has caused the
government huge problems
the vaccine has helped to restore its
ratings a little bit
but a lot of us i think are surprised at
how the pandemic has in some ways been
even more difficult for labour as an
opposition
that it has been for johnson as a
government
yes we've had kirstama giving a big
speech today
briefed out as a moment not quite a
reset
in the terms of uh labour advisors
working on that speech
but definitely after a difficult few
weeks where kirstama has received a lot
of criticism
for his leadership of lack of impact of
his leadership
i think his speech was supposed to be a
big moment but once again
uh it is generating a few headlines but
is is not the top story
and i think that uh those around kissed
armor really do now believe that
actually it's very hard to do opposition
politics in a pandemic
conversely you could say uh surely it
could be uh
in a way uh when you have a government
which has overseen a death toll over a
hundred thousand
uh something that the labour leader
could respond to quite effectively
but they have definitely taken the
position that they are in a difficult
spot and the public do not want to see
two parties scrapping at a time of
national crisis
so i think that when you speak to those
around kierstarma they really believe
that when
he'll start to make his impact issue in
a year or so
they it's not so much they're writing
this off completely but they don't see
it as that cool period where he is
making that impact
i think the question is how long do
those around him tolerate that because
already there is quite a lot of
frustration at the pace he is going at
we were talking katie in late autumn
that if the johnson government didn't
get his act together there could be a
leadership crisis in the tory party by
spring
and the vaccine seems to have been his
get out of jail card to avoid that
isn't the makings of a leadership crisis
now in the labour party
so i think it's an interesting one
because i think we're going to head to a
period where christian will come under a
lot of scrutiny there's already a lot of
pressure on him to change his shadow
cabinet
and i don't think it's a particularly
enjoyable period for him and his team
and i think it's going to stay however
when you speak to labour mps and those
on the left and you pose this question
of well will kirsten make it to the next
election they often at laugh
laugh at you because they say
historically you know it
the tory party often will do something
rather brutal they will find the way to
respond
and deal and get the person they think
is most likely to win votes but
that they say that is not the labor way
and therefore it's more likely kirsten
will have a painful time
in the build to the next election than
actually a crisis where people look to
move him
i'm quite surprised james the way
kirsten hasn't been able to make
the times uh work in his favor because
there's one way of looking at it in
which they are propitious
um you know the pandemic is probably the
most serious
challenge this country has faced since
the second world war
victory in the second world war demanded
a huge scaling up of government
uh of government doing all sorts of
things that he'd never done before
and we won and in 1945 labor said
look what government did there we need
to continue with big government and
build on that and government
can do more and we got the atlea
government which won by a landslide
even though churchill had won the war if
you're on the left
you could argue exactly the same surely
on the pandemic that it's taken
massive government spending and
intervention to get on top of this
pandemic
and we need more government
post-pandemic to do
all sorts of things that labour
governments should be doing
but he doesn't seem to frame it in that
way yeah and you can add to that that
the government has
appears to have discovered the magic
money tree during this pandemic you know
it is paid
80 of the wages of a huge percentage of
the private sector workforce
and yet it is still borrowing at at very
cheap rates um i think the problem
for uh kiestarma is the corbin years
have left labour convinced that they
need to to recover their reputation for
you know fiscal responsibility so they
have been
kind of reluctant to embrace this moment
and and how
cheaply governments can borrow because i
think they worry that voters will just
hear
you know the same old labor uh that you
know they always run out of somebody
else's money if they start talking about
borrowing huge sums
i think the other problem that you face
is this is akin to
uh the war ends in 45 and then churchill
has three
three years before he has to go to the
electorate again
and you know in that three year period
churchill probably would have introduced
the national health service you know
how many of the issues would that have
taken away that labour fought the 45
election on
and i think one of the challenges for
them is you know tory economics is
shifting quite dramatically during this
crisis
uh tory party attitudes towards
industrial policy is shifting
just look at the way in which you know
people regard uh the vaccine
uh and the links between uh oxford and
astrazeneca and the government as
as an example of you know how you do
industrial policy so
i think that's that's the other
challenge for labor i think
starman's big problem is but on the he's
a cautious politician
an on becoming leader he essentially
took a bet that in the british system
uh oppositions don't win elections
governments lose them
and so he took this very cautious
approach
and last autumn as you were saying when
lots of things were going wrong for the
government and boris johnson was coming
under pressure
you know labor went ahead in the polls
and and this seemed like
a bet he seemed to have detoxified the
labor party post corbyn
and he see and the government seemed to
be making enough mistakes
that uh denying the tourism majority at
the next election was looking a distinct
possibility for them
the problem is that if you are waiting
for the government to lose the election
when something goes right for the
government as the vaccine program has
gone right
you're left with very little to stand on
and i think that is the problem for him
right now
you know his whole strategy is it
inherently depends
on the government making mistakes so
when the government gets onto a better
run
he is left quite exposed james kenny
thanks for that always bringing us up to
date
on the latest in westminster and what
might be happening next week
now on next week the government uh says
it won't bring in official vaccine
passports
but that's not stopping businesses and
organizations from creating their own
what does this mean for those who don't
want to get vaccinated in particular
what does it mean for our ethnic
communities
who we know are much more vaccine
hesitant
i'm joined by trevor phillips times
columnist former chair
of the equalities commission and
itinerant writer for the spectator
and rod little a spectator columnist
welcome
to you both rod you wrote about
vaccine passports this week i still
wasn't sure in the end if you were for
or against them
no i'm not sure either to be honest what
i was talking about
i read that i read that right then do
you got it right andrew
um i i i was looking at what the
government was trying to do
and why they had moved away in in the
last couple of weeks from the idea of a
mandatory
uh vaccine passport and it occurred to
me that
it was going to be in trouble uh simply
through
through grounds of discrimination that
we would be in a position where
large quantities of of our british
uh black ethnic minority people
are reluctant to have the vaccine and
that would see them excluded from a
whole manner of things
such as cinemas such as possibly
transport such as restaurants such as
pubs and so on
and i think the government thought it
would be rather better if if business
took the brunt
for that particular uh uh problem rather
than themselves
that was my worry and you raised that
about alabama in the segregation
south before the civil rights in the 60s
and uh but i wonder if that's a
is that a fair comparison i mean
if i if i'm a bus driver in montgomery
alabama
i don't let you onto my bus because
you're black
there's nothing you can do about the
color of your skin
if i'm a restaurant owner i'm not
letting you in whatever your color
because you haven't got a vaccine
passport you can change that
no sure one sure sure andrew and
i was being a little bit facetious uh
but nonetheless
i got that bit too wrong
there are many in uh the black and
ethnic minority community you would you
would say that it amounts to pretty much
the same thing and would argue
strongly that the reason for lack of
take-up but i'm sure trevor knows more
about this than i do
that one of the reasons for the lack of
take-up is because and this has been
quoted in the united states on
vaccination programs before now
uh uh historic injustice at the hands of
the health service for black and
minority people so in in the end the
chap on the bus
uh it's it's effectively the same if not
quite as brutal
okay trevor what do you make of this
well
i i read ron's piece and one thing you
can say about
rod's journalism is never knowingly
undercooked
um i think he's taking it to
but there is a basic and an important
point that he raises
here um i think the answer if you're
asking specifically
about the issue of uh what rod describes
mandatory
vaccine passports well there are two
elements that mandatory
no i don't think so i think that gets us
into very difficult territory
how do you police it how do you qualify
all that stuff
but that's seen passports that
demonstrate that you've had it in the
same way as you do
for yellow fever if you're going to
certain countries and so on i don't see
any problem with that
at all i think actually that would be to
everybody's advantage and today we can
do that pretty
simply by putting an apple on your phone
so i'm
i'm completely up for that and i don't
really see that there's any
uh necessary probability
of um discrimination in that i think
that there's a bigger problem behind
this
which is that if i can put it bluntly
the government or anybody else really
knows what they're talking about
on this and we're hearing a lot about
we know that there is vector reduction
well what we've got is some opinion
polls that tell us that but we don't
know that
actually people from minorities are
taking it up in
uh less frequently than the others i've
had my own vaccine by the way given to
me by
a chinese nurse who really made me feel
she said she said to her mate i don't
check this guy because i don't think
he's
old enough to have it so it made me feel
rather good about it and i suspect
that's going on all around
the health service so you have to i
think that there's a lot of knowledge
if you look at the nhs you paid the
chinese nurse for the vaccine i can see
not at all
she was lovely i think there's a lot of
knowledge being taught there's a lot of
nonsense being taught
so for example it's routinely said that
ethnic minorities are more likely to die
if you look at the ons data week
by week from april last year the
the the split between uh white and
non-white
has been 86 14
86 14 absolutely steadily every single
week and as you will know
that is the split in the population as a
whole now it may be
that some minority groups are uh
dying a greater rate but that's probably
balanced by those who are
less likely to die it may also be that
minorities are more likely to become
infected but because they have a younger
egg profile less
likely to die the problem is we do not
know if i can point the thing that
government they have been absolutely
scandalously i mean scandalously
lacks in trying to understand the
dynamics of this issue
and they have got many things absolutely
wrong on this question
i i take issue with one thing that
trevor says there which is
the lack of data on black and ethnic
minorities taking up the vaccine
there is quite a bit of data it's
sporadic i quote a couple in the piece i
was writing one is from i think north
north staffordshire uh where uh
and i think this was largely bangladeshi
uh uh uh patients uh to gp surgeries
were ten times less likely
to take up the vaccine that were their
uh white neighbors
and there's there was a similar study i
think the government's own figures
uh have also suggested that amongst
african
and uh uh uh british caribbean people
it's the take-up is somewhere in the
region of 50 as opposed to
round about just over 80 percent for for
for white people so i think there is a
difference there but but but i think
underneath that difference i i i don't
think it's as simple as
uh i think socioeconomics come into it
uh in some cases
in some parts of the of our muslim
community i was talking to mohammed
abbasi
the leader of the uh association of
british muslims today
and the various muslim groups have done
an enormous amount to make sure
uh that the muslim community is taking
up their vaccine
but there is there's still some worry in
some parts particularly amongst
bangladeshis
that the vaccine might have some
contaminatory pig stuff in it something
like that
it's there's still that slight
resistance there so there's loads and
loads of different reasons
why and i think most of them are
socioeconomic
uh why minority people may not be taking
them let me go back to trevor
trevor no let's see if we can
reestablish her contact with trevor and
we'll get
get back to him um he does seem to have
frozen rod let me come back to
to you just for a second so it seems
that
i think you and trevor both agree that
the gut the there shouldn't be mandatory
sort of government-endorsed passports uh
vaccine passports
but what about the private sector
putting aside you your sort of alabama
uh analogy i see trevor's back with us
i'll come to him in a minute
let me finish this question i mean for
example
we hope it's maybe a long shot we might
this summer be able to do our famous
spectator summer party
now you know it well it's usually in a
steamy july night
people are crammed in in a go they're
outdoors but it's
pretty crammed in there's not much
social distancing
if we were to say to people you're
welcome to come to
our summer party we're managing to do it
this year
but you have to have a vaccine passport
what would be wrong with that
i don't see that anything would be wrong
with that i'm with trevor on that
the the problem is how it's perceived
and there will be people who try to whip
up the cause of discrimination
uh and they will say that it is that
that is it's simply discriminating
firstly in favor of the affluent because
we know as well
the affluent and the elderly are the two
two trenches of the population who are
most likely to take up the vaccine
so that wouldn't particularly hurt the
spectator summer party
as it's comprised largely of the
affluent of the elderly
oh it's full of young folks it's a
multivital event too
yes you're quite right uh but i i think
uh i think in the i think in the broader
world
some people will find a problem with
that okay let me go back to trevor i'm
delighted we've established
contact again you wanted to reply there
uh
to to rod particularly on on the data
let's come back to that
and tell us what we know let me say i i
probably think i think there is some
thing going on but the problem is we do
not know
um by the way on the question you've
just been discussing the truth of the
matter is why are you going to pay any
attention to any idiot
who thinks that the possibility of
discrimination
is a bigger deal than the fact that
black people might actually die from
this thing i mean
frankly i don't think we need to be
bothered with those people our problem
the problem we've got at the moment is
that there are lots of things we do not
actually
know to be true we need the data for
this reason
to understand what it is that is going
wrong
i do not believe that for example the
problem is
language proficiency fewer than two
percent of people in this country cannot
read
or understand english well enough to
understand the messages are coming for
forward nor do i think there is some
craziness about what's going on in the
internet we can't
one day be complaining about digital
exclusion of minorities
and then say they're not turning up
because they're all busy on twitter
take imbibing the conspiracy theories
that's all nonsense i think there are
probably two or three things we need to
look at
first of all historic mistrust of
authority i think rod's got that right
secondly i think we need to look at
where
vaccinations taking place in the united
states they've shown
in massachusetts that on average uh
vaccination centers
uh white people are twice as likely to
live within
a mile of a vaccination center as black
people and that's part of the example
and the third thing which nobody wants
to talk about but is a real thing
is that we need to think about
people who may be undocumented and who
are not coming forward
because what they believe is any contact
with the authorities of this kind
will turn the eye of sauron the
immigration authorities on them
and that actually they may get a jab but
the next week they'll be out of the
country and that's the thing that we've
got to try and deal with
give those people confidence that the
system isn't going to lead
to them being targeted by immigration
authorities
i'm interested though trevor uh that you
say that the figures are not as
clear-cut as some of the coverage
has been that we we need to be careful
in talking about
the the uh the uptake they're being that
different
from the rest of the population well the
narrative is that the narrative has
overcome
any regard for data and as you know
andrew my businesses
now data scientists and you i can't tell
you
how furious i i mean to take roger rod's
point i understand why he believes that
but i can tell you for certain we'll
publish data we'll publish a paper on
this probably the next three or four
weeks
there is one large local authority we've
run we've run the records of about a
million patients
and what we know is that there are about
a half a million
records in that authority which has
a couple of million people in it which
have no ethnicity data on them
so the date on which the nhs is working
it has a huge margin of error
there's loads of things we do not know
but people are asserting
confidently and unfortunately
that will probably mean that we make
we're probably making mistakes
taking the wrong steps and ignoring for
example
very small groups who need some special
treatment i said that's it rod i'll give
you a final word on this
i think the the fascinating thing is uh
the the take-up of the vaccine in europe
it seems to me almost certain that one
of the reasons for the very high take-up
in in the uk
is the fact that it's a bit of
patriotism in there
there's a bit of good news story that we
were developing the vaccine
and have done better than the rest of
europe in getting it out and i think
that's
rather swung more people than were
expected behind the vaccine
but it's it's also fascinating to look
at the the various
the various reasons in europe
particularly amongst countries which
suffered under
totalitarian governments uh the visigrad
countries where take-up is very low um
east germany where take-up is a lot
lower than it is in west germany
but germany again as another as another
example they had a
a much-hated vaccination program from
1874
compulsory for smallpox and it did
wonders it eradicated smallpox from
germany
but it was very unpopular particularly
under the weinreimer government
but because of the side effects and some
children dying in schools as a
consequence of this
it was all carried out in schools so
there's a long historical memory
of compulsory vaccination and a big
government bearing down upon people
and that's one reason why they take up
so low another reason i think could be
the
uh the obverse to what i was saying
about britain
that in europe they have mishandled the
vaccine appallingly
uh it has been slow uh sluggish under
the eu
and i suspect that that has its effect
upon what people
think about the vaccine in the end it's
a it's a fascinating topic
i think rod's got a really important
point there we talk about
minorities and we constantly are
thinking about people of color
let's bear in mind we have at least
nearly a million
people from poland uh in this country
plus from other east european countries
many of whom have parents and
grandparents
who lived under authoritarian regimes
who frankly could not be trusted and
it's not
surprising if some of that if you like
memory
would discourage them from trusting
any authority even in this country that
says oh come
don't worry we're going to look after
you because frankly
behind the iron curtain for the best
part of 70 years
we're going to look after you meant you
weren't coming back home
gentlemen we'll leave it there thank you
for joining me on spectator tv rod
and trevor there let's stick with the
vaccine though but let's move on to the
vaccine diplomacy
because you do need passports to travel
but this is diplomacy not vaccine
passports
the british government can't get its
people vaccinated fast enough and that's
true of meds
many of the western democracies but
china and russia have been sending
millions of dozens
of their coveted vaccines abroad it's
all about increasing their influence in
the post-pandemic world
it's a new great game which is the topic
of our cover story uh for this week's
magazine written
by the spectators broadcast editor host
of our chinese whispers podcast cindy
you she joins
me now cindy so bottom line
china and russia but especially china
using the distribution of its vaccine to
developing countries
to further its influence on foreign
policy
yes it's it's an obvious thing to try to
do when you think about it because
uh even as early as last year china and
russia were sending out their ppe
donations to other countries when there
was a global shortage
china certainly was sending out its own
doctors which obviously at that point
had known quite a lot about the virus by
march
april kind of time and now it's vaccines
so this phase is
the truly life-saving phase and what a
lot of countries around the world are
experiencing is that
actually they might have fizer orders or
they might have astrazeneca oxford
orders
but a lot of these deliveries are not
reliable and might not even start until
later this year
pushing them into the hands into the
arms of china and russia
who at least were china you know they're
not vaccinating their own people
at the breakneck pace i think we could
expect china to do
because they're just directing all of
their vaccines abroad so president xi's
vaccination target for late march is
only four percent of the population
that's
an incredibly slow pace from the country
because they see the soft power
potential here
so just to be clear in you could say
that
soft power for the let's take china soft
power for the chinese leadership which
comes from
uh exporting these vaccines in some ways
becoming is giving greater priority
than the regime vaccinating its own
people
yes i think so and but you know the
caveat to that is that china has
uh according to official figures
defeated covert within its borders so
obviously
there was that january outbreak where 22
million people at one point weighing
lockdown
but since then that outbreak has been
controlled daily figures show
maybe less than five new cases each day
and so most chinese people don't feel
like they need to be vaccinated anytime
soon
because they don't feel like they're
going to come across it when they go out
go about their daily business
so given there's a lack of pressure from
underneath uh the this
chinese communist party is finding it
easy to make that calculation
to export that abroad it seemed reading
your uh your cover story this week that
uh
it's almost like a new scramble for
africa in particular
the the chinese and the russians going
into zimbabwe was
one country you you mentioned uh going
into
african countries and offering the
pandemic
in areas where the chinese in particular
already have some influence i mean
there's been quite a lot of chinese
involvement in zimbabwe for example
exactly countries like zimbabwe have
amazing natural resources
rare earths that are so important to
develop high technology
components like mobile phones electric
cars
all that sort of stuff that china
controls a lot of the wild supply of
you know china's belt and road
initiative that has been established in
the last five or so years
is essentially building these
infrastructure links along with the
diplomatic links in order for china to
grow faster
and bigger and of course some of these
recipient countries are
also getting a good deal out of it
especially the government's in control
of it
so as i say in my piece that a lot of
the strongmen leaders of the world
gravitate towards beijing's gifts you
know you've got president managua
of zimbabwe mugabe's successor saying
that his country feels greatly honored
by the chinese donation of vaccinations
you've got president erdogan
taking a picture of him getting jabbed
with sanofarm one of china's two vaccine
producers
you've got duterte philippines very
controversial president
who you know has literally talked about
a violent and fatal war on drugs
squeezing hand sanitizer onto the
beijing emissary
in a very attentive way so all these
strong men um
love chinese investment and vaccinations
is the one way to prove
that china's friendship is worth a lot
and and i thought that was a fascinating
point that china was using the
distribution of the vaccine to kind of
help bolster
a strong men and their old men of uh
whom china
approves and that even went as far as
the leader of hungary who approved
sino farm one of the two major vaccines
that china produces
yeah and viktor orban is not one of
these countries you know he doesn't lead
one of these countries that doesn't have
you know options he's part of the eu
scheme he doesn't think he's going to
get enough jabs that way
so that's why he's turned to saino farm
he's also turned to sputnik russia's jab
but with cyanofarm he goes one step
further he says he's going to take the
sino-farm
vaccines at 79 efficacy over the pfizer
one
at 95 percent efficacy because he says
the chinese have known as virus for the
longest
i'm not sure that was quite on brand for
the beijing embassy
i noticed you say one i think it's
cynovac
been sending out even though it's
only very recently that it actually got
final approval but it didn't stop them
exporting it abroad
no and it didn't you know it didn't seem
to matter for the countries that
imported sinovac
either a lot of it was done under
emergency uh vaccination schemes which
china of course
has been using itself to vaccinate up to
a million people
domestically uh but yes you're right
cyanoback hasn't
until this month it didn't get
regulatory approval within china
even now sino-vac and sino-farm are not
being regulated for use
in the over 60s within china that hasn't
stopped them before being used in the
elderly in places like indonesia
so you know there's an interesting
question as to you know the different
regulatory
authorities and their different
standards and why the chinese themselves
don't think that their jobs
work for the elderly or safe enough for
the elderly just yet so you've got a
situation where erdogan's been
vaccinated
but maybe the 67 year old president xi
hasn't even been vaccinated yet
it's interesting too when you look to
the question of how does the west
respond because of course
the democratic pressure in the west is
on the governments to vaccinate their
own people first before they
start sending vaccines abroad but you
give one example of a
involving the united kingdom using
manufacturing capabilities in
india to produce the oxford jabs
for export to poorer countries
in the region and this was one way of
which
the west was trying to combat some of
the
vaccine geopolitics of china and russia
tell us more about this indian venture
yes so this is very interesting china
for you know the last two decades may
have been a factory of the world
but india has is still the king when it
comes to vaccine manufacturing
the serum institute of india produces is
the largest vaccine manufacturer in the
world
in pre-covert times and they've signed a
deal with you know
a few different vaccine producers among
which is the oxford astrazeneca jab
um they think that they can produce up
to a billion of this
this year and so while the uk's
diplomatic focus
or why the uk's nominal focus is on the
british citizens
the oxford astrazeneca jab has been
given to the sii
in india to be produced on mass and the
modi government that
is distributing them especially in asia
so you've got an interesting situation
where
india and china are fighting over their
neighbours like sri lanka and bangladesh
and for those two countries india has
won over and those two countries have
opted
for the oxford jab instead you've also
got an awkward situation where it seems
like the oxford jab might not be
universally
applicable in the sense that in south
africa where the new strain has come
from
the oxford doesn't seem as effective so
india did
export some to that country but now it
doesn't seem to be really working there
um sputnik has applied for approval in
south africa so you can see that china
russia are never far behind
no indeed i just finally cindy uh
we've seen the british working in india
to do something which is not designed to
counter china or russia but it could
have that effect am i right in thinking
we haven't heard anything from the biden
administration about this yet
yeah so the biden administration on the
first day of him coming in symbolically
kind of stopped their departure from the
wha in a sort of
you know we're not trump way um and they
also joined
in kovacs which is the who's developing
world vaccine scheme
uh they threw some money at it but it's
not nearly enough
america has also ordered like many other
high-income countries many more vaccines
than it will ever need
uh which you know adds to the pressure
the supply pressures around the world
and you know america i think it's biden
itself
himself he aims to vaccinate all
americans by july
so the focus is very much like the
british focus on on the home
home turf and which has led to you know
longtime
american allies like even mexico to turn
to sputnik
for help because they can't get their
hands on any pfizer so i think the
question is this before biden came into
power there was all this talk about how
trump was
the obstacle to this international
alliance against china in particular
now that biden is in office you know
what is he actually
doing that's different to unite these
western countries to see off
this china chinese challenge and it
doesn't seem like there's much going on
there
yeah at the moment no i thought it was
fascinating sydney in your pieces
at the way uh the russians had got in to
provide mexico with the vaccine
uh whereas almost nothing if anything
had come from
america that's change days indeed cindy
thanks for being with us
uh it's great to hear from you you can
read cindy's excellent cover piece on
the geopolitics of vaccine
the vaccine was it's an issue uh which
the spectators have been ahead of the
game on and cindy's
cover story brings us up to date you can
also hear from cindy
on her podcast it's available at
spectator dot co dot
u k slash chinese whispers that's
spectator dot co
dot uk chinese whispers
now remember if you subscribe to the
spectator's youtube channel it's free
you'll never miss another episode just
click the subscribe button
at the bottom right of the screen now
and our final segment for today
what makes the english english in the
lead article of the spectators arts
pages this week journalist dan hitchens
writes about the renewed interest in the
anglo-saxons and the anglo-saxon period
thanks to the netflix film the dig about
saturn who
and the bbc series called the detectors
he joins the show now together with
harry mount he's the editor
of the audience magazine and author of
how england made
the english dan let let me come to you
first is it
film and tv that accounts for this new
interest in
the anglo-saxon period you go back
further you could say
famous heaney biggest english language
poet
v8 translating beowulf was what kicked
off the entrance
but i think in the end it is um film and
tv that really popularized this
the other big event i suppose was 2009
when the staffordshire hoard was
discovered this amazing uh biggest haul
of anglo-saxon
gold ever found which um sort of opened
a window into another age
as well because anglo-saxon kings
needs a lot of treasure it's how you
reward your followers
and so they had a vast amount of um
this very impressive often
breathtakingly beautiful
jeweled sword hilts and that sort of
thing all buried in one place
that really caught the public
imagination and i think that's
part of what's um what's sort of laid
the ground for
for things like the dig which is quite a
surprising thing to be a big
netflix film you know it's not about the
nazis or the tudors it's about
people or super or superman or superman
or a kind of downton abbey thing
it's the upper ship burial from the 7th
century and yet
people were sort of fascinated about it
there's some idea about a lost world
there which i think really appeals to
people the one thing that came through
from the digging on saturn who and also
in the staffordshire horde story
is that it seemed to open our eyes a bit
i think i remember a bit in the dick
where one of the archaeologists
is pretty sure this is a viking find um
it's not anglo-saxon because the
anglo-saxons weren't that sophisticated
uh and it turns out that they were and
that seemed to be one
of the significant points of both
findings is that
correct yeah i mean i think i like the
dig less than
most people seem to see that it was a
bit clunky but the nice thing about it
being clunky was that you did get
lines like the dark ages are no longer
dark so it's this sense that
the anglo-saxons are being rehabilitated
that
you know the discovery that they had um
particular kind of coinage i think it
was in the film showed this
sophisticated form of government but you
can look further i mean the artistic
events are amazing
the uh administrative changes brought in
by alfred the greats
which form a lot of our you know current
systems that have derived
from that um harry's written about how
you know the very place names of the
country you know most of them were
full before that time so a lot of things
take for granted and a lot of very
great artistic cultural political
achievements date from that time
and there's some consciousness of that
that seems to be coming back now
harry what do you think accounts for
this interest in
the anglo-saxon period in that role in
our history
well i think the dig is a big reason but
also it's just a gradual realization
of the way anglo-saxon history has been
marginalized i think it's partly because
of
those two big dates for 10 a.d
when the romans leave britain and 1066
most famous state of all battle of
hastings and people tend to think
correctly that a foreign invader left in
410 with the romans
a foreign invader arrived in 1066 of
william the conqueror
but they wrongly think that in between
nothing happened well that's an
incredibly long time 650 years
that's longer than the romans were here
if you go forward from 1066 that takes
you to the 18th century
and as dan says in his great piece so
much of
uh particularly english history is set
in place
by the anglo-saxons so there's a
monarchy
um the church is set up there's coinage
as dan
said our county system norfolk and
devonshire were there in the
11th century um and most importantly the
language and the language we're speaking
today
uh when you talk about english well
two-thirds of the words
in the dictionary uh from latin or greek
but we don't use so many of them most of
the words we're using today the three of
us talking
are based in anglo-saxon particularly we
won't be using any swear words but most
of our swear words
are anglo-saxons shorter ones too
exactly
but um so so so much of what we're doing
and saying today is thanks to the
anglo-saxons but they were marginalized
for a long time in history and i think
we're just gradually revealing how
important they were
well the long the longevity of
anglo-saxon
influence interests me because in that
period from the departure of the romans
and the arrival of william the conqueror
i mean they were bashed around a lot uh
not long after
they arrived the viking raids were
endless
and when they finally saw these viking
raids
off and they and alfred begins to create
more of a state that covers a big chunk
of what we now think of england
king commute arrives and and the danes
win and the
the danes control it and then no sooner
or the anglo-saxons coming to terms with
that
then the normans arrive and and that is
a very different kind of invasion
because
they basically attempted to snuff out
the anglo-saxon
culture with uh with a almost a nazi
ferocity
uh and for three four hundred years the
leaders of our country did not speak
english or anglo-saxon
at all and yet it still somehow survived
in the end
these norman kings ended up speaking
english what was in it that kept it
going harry
uh well uh you're right the uh english
kings after winning the congress
went on speaking french for 200 or so
years but actually
uh most people in the country it's not
like suddenly overnight they started
speaking
french and i think there was a great
continuity so
actually again we like to think of 1066
as a big
break but in fact uh winning the
conqueror was a cousin of
edward the confessor hebrew confessor
spent a lot of time in
normandy and so there's a continuity
there in terms of just the blood
of monarchs but even things like
churches
as dan said most um settlements
in britain certainly in england were
there
uh set up by the anglo-saxons and their
place names are very
very often anglo-saxon so it's not like
the normans turned up and said
right we're kicking you all out we're
changing your place names you're
changing your language
there was a continuity and something
like say westminster abbey
was founded by edward confessor in 1065
he built a huge abbey there
that then was largely taken over by
william the conqueror and expanded
although you can still see the
anglo-saxon routes there so they took
over the government obviously
but actually underneath there was this
strong anglo-saxon
continuity which as i say we can see in
our language and place names as you say
the
the people as opposed to the elite kept
on speaking yes the language too dan is
there into having
perhaps a marginalized this period in
english history would be what were
called the dark ages and it was inside
it was in the day the dark ages are no
longer dark
uh is is it um is there a danger of the
pendulum may go the other way we begin
to mythologize this i read a lot about
how the
the anglo-saxon wittens are really the
forerunners of our
parliament and that's the start of
parliamentary democracy that there was a
anglo-saxon individualism and community
as well and all the rest of it that uh
it made it a kind of magical period has
the pendulum gone too much the other way
i think it's a risk of seeing it as a
kind of
uh warrior age and emphasizing the sort
of
bloodthirsty darwinian struggle which
definitely was there but then there's
another story of incredible
sort of creativity of blending
influences so many influences coming
from the continent as well if you look
at how
art develops how um
like student looted manuscripts
are picking up on non-christian trends
in art there's
just amazing examples of intellectual
achievements
as well and i think it's that side of
seeing how much was done
that um that could be emphasized even if
it's not
kind of a perfect model of a a peaceful
speech or however
well i think you brought an important
point of course the anglo-saxons which
have often been misused as a kind of
racial purity were actually rather
diverse because they were
english there were danes they were brits
they were the viking
raids and all that others that i've
missed missed out but harry
is this uh renewed interest in
anglo-saxon roots uh renewed interest in
in what happened in our history before
the normans
and how it survived the normans has
brexit done something to bring this on
as well
is this a a re-examination of our
national identity
i think less so brexit but certainly
um scottish independence and the
possibility of
welsh independence as well that it's
extraordinary if you look at a map
of the development of anglo-saxon
england as dan referred to in his
article
england is warring with those different
factions through the anglo-saxon period
and by the time you get to the 11th
century england is largely unified
and they're beginning to refer
themselves to refer to themselves as the
angli the
angles but if you look at those maps the
borders of wales and scotland
are not identical but they're pretty
much the same today
as then we are not yet having battles
between
wessex and mercier here are we i think
that's unlikely to happen
but i think the unified england really
uh was in place by the 10th or 11th
century
that those problems were dealing with
now with a possible scottish
independence
and and less likely a welsh independence
go back
to england really being set in stone
by the anglo-saxons and dan that just to
finish up with you that was one thing
that did make england
different or what became england at that
time
it was an island race so that makes a
difference though i
in fact was an island also meant it was
easy to attack from the sea as the
vikings
quickly discovered and so so did others
uh but also the the the growth of an
anglo-saxon
uh community or covering most of
of england even up to northumbria which
for many years had been
had been given to the scots or taken by
them that meant that you didn't have the
kind of internal
battles civil wars in these days that
you had in france or italy or even
in spain and germany that marked england
out as different didn't it
right there's an amazingly continuous uh
story of kind of
internal peace and um one thing in the
articles i spoke to
tom holland the historian who's written
obviously about anglo-saxon as well as
everything else
and he sees it as a a hopeful story in
certain ways that you get a kind of
common purpose
emerging among kingdoms which could have
been at each other's throats
and had been for parts of their history
so he as a unionist sees this
um maybe not as an exact model but as a
sign you can get very different
identities
very different histories actually coming
together and
agree to live together well all right
and we'll leave it there and harry
excellent article thank you for that you
can read it in the spectator
uh this week it's the lead to our arts
pages uh uh harry's book is how england
made the english it's an
excellent read as well harry thank you
uh for joining
all going uh well at the old e2 it's
good to have you here on spectator tv
pleasure to be here
and if you're interested in addition to
harry's book and of course dan's article
uh
robert toomes uh history of the english
or history of england
uh the earlier part of that goes through
the anglo-saxon period
it's a pretty good place to start uh
it's a broad view but it's a pretty good
place to start if you want to learn a
bit about it
and then to learn more after that that's
robert tubes the cambridge
historian that's it for this week thanks
to all of our guests and once again
to our very special sponsor charles
stanley for sponsoring
the week in 60 minutes charles stanley
is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms it's one
of the oldest firms
on the london stock exchange as always
let us have your thoughts on how we're
doing what we're not doing
what we should be doing to spectator tv
at spectator.com.uk
join us again next week bye bye
[Music]
you